[موسيقى
] رهبان شاولين في الصين هم
نظام قديم محاط بالغموض
يقضون حياتهم في تعلم الكونغ فو والفلسفة البوذية ،
يمكنك اختيار جزأين من مخططاتي أو
اختيار الصلاة ولكنني اخترت الجمع بين
الاثنين معًا اخترت أسوأ طريقة
بعد الانشقاق  من الصين الشيوعية ،
وجد راهب شاولين نفسه يعيش في
نيويورك حيث قام بتدريب بعض العملاء الفريدين
بدءًا من نجوم السينما وحتى فناني الهيب هوب.
قال التدريب الصيفي الأول في الحديقة أنك تريد التدريس استمر في
الدراسة وقلت لا مشكلة
، أنا أتحدث مع الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم
لنشر أسوأ الجبر براتلي
لدي طلاب يأتون من كل مكان
في عالمنا هذا يأتي هنا لمدة
أسبوع واحد فقط أحيانًا بين  لقد أتيت
إلى هنا لتعلم ما إذا كانت شعبية Yun Ming قد
زادت من تعاليمه وبدأت في
جذب انتباه أحد
أشهر فناني الهيب هوب في نيويورك الذين
قضى Shifu سنوات في التدريب معهم
RZA من wu-tang clan ذهبوا
إلى حد الظهور في الفيديو الموسيقي
لمعبد شاولين إلى Wu Tang Clan إنهم يحبون
الثقافة الصينية لقد أحبوا
مخططاتي لكن chien-ming يؤمن بشدة
أن فوائد شاولين يمكن
تكييفها لأي فرد  يمكن لأي شخص
الاستفادة منها لأن نوعًا مختلفًا
من الأساليب لأشخاص مختلفين لم يبلغوا
سنًا ولم أخبرهم مطلقًا أنني لم أتأكد من الركض
إلى الأبد
[موسيقى]
أريد الوصول إلى أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص
في حياة ثمينة
كهدف نهائي